yesterday the arizona cardinals dropped
a tweet right around lunchtime i was out
running errands and i saw and that my
car was stopped i do not check my phone
while i drive chris sims you'll be happy
to know thank you very very strongly way
to go but while my car was in park i
checked and i saw that the arizona
cardinals tweeted so we have some news
and i became very intrigued by that and
i was paying attention as i made my
various stops i would check my phone
again go to the bank check the phone go
to the pharmacy check the phone go to
the dry cleaners check the phone go pick
up lunch check the phone waiting for the
cardinals to tell us what the news was
and the news ultimately was this
carson palmer is joining the team's ring
of honor and my position is and again
this is not intended to be an insult to
carson palmer it may be but this isn't
news you tease right this oh we have a
big announcement coming stay tuned for
further information that we are about to
share with you it's not teasable just
announce it nobody else teases that
they're going to put somebody in the
ring of honor they just say that they're
in the ring of honor so it created all
sorts of unnecessary buzz and
speculation that the cardinals were up
to something that was tease-worthy this
isn't tease worthy that's my little rant
for the day we didn't do airing of
grievances today that's my grievance on
a wednesday but here's my other grief
how are the cardinals the cardinals have
been around chris
since
1900 right i mean they went by a
different name but they are the oldest
team in the nfl also one of the least
successful franchises in league history
they were founded in 1898 and they've
won two championships in the nfl 1925
and 1947 they have three quarterbacks in
their ring of honor including carson
palmer jim hart kurt warner and palmer
now there may be other guys that we
could say are deserving but it's amazing
to me that your team has been that bad
for that many years that you have so few
quarterbacks that have even bubbled up
to the point where they make it to that
immortality the team hands out to select
members of the franchise it is amazing
and i think ultimately that's why we're
seeing carson palmer in it not to take
anything away from carson palmer he had
a phenomenal career but you know what i
have sat here and you know with most
organizations gone oh man yeah this
carson palmer what he's done here for uh
this organization oh he's definitely
getting the ring of honor no i think it
fits because there is lack of history
and lack of greatness with the arizona
cardinals in general and they're trying
to create more history with name guys
that did have success within the
organization and because there's not a
lot of them yeah it's you know they
their guys like carson palmer get
thrusted into there you know even though
that they might not
have the same credentials what it takes
to get into the ring of honor for the
green bay packers or some other teams in
football like i'm saying but to what you
said earlier too i mean yeah i think
that we got a big announcement that was
a little misleading i certainly was
thinking something a little bigger along
those lines other thing that just pops
into my head you know and this is to me
where you know neil lomax if if carson
palmer is in is in the ring of honor for
the cardinals neil lomax deserves to be
too see what this looks like to me is if
you were the quarterback of a team that
was winning you can get in but if you
were a really good quarterback in the
80s early 90s and did a lot of good
things for our franchise but our team
didn't win you don't get in and neil
lomax i mean yeah those cardinals teams
he played for from 81 to 88 weren't all
that great i understand that but he's
still 22 000 yards career passer for the
cardinals you know uh what what is it
136 touchdowns uh so he's one of the
better quarterbacks in the history of
the sport too where i want to go well
just because he didn't get to the nfc
championship game like carson palmer
doesn't
put him in the ring of honor he should
be there
well and and look carson palmer is
fourth all time
on the passing list for uh yardage for
the cardinals yeah two of the guys in
front of him aren't in the ring of honor
you mentioned lomax the other one jake
plummer there you go right jake jake
plummer has has 82 starts for the
cardinals palmer had 60. and lomax at
101 yeah so i look
there's a reason why the cardinals have
just kind of been the cardinals over the
years and you know they have had some
moments and i feel like at times they're
figuring out how to compete
at a at a relevant level in the nfl but
i mean this is a long history of just
not good quarterback play and there
aren't many guys we could name that
should be in lomax and plummer are
pretty much it they've had a lot of guys
now patty driscoll was a quarterback
back in the 1920s and i think he's in
their ring of honor as well so maybe we
can say there's four but his numbers
obviously from the early 20s before the
forward pass probably i don't know
he's in there he is in there just so you
know i got the list in front of me right
now
and here's the other thing too you know
we talk about carson palmer being the
quarterback for five years i don't think
there's ever been a coach of the
franchise for more than six wow i think
jim hanafan
and ken wisenhunt are tied at six i may
and maybe bruce bruce arians didn't do
six he did five
so that it's been a revolving door at
coach and not a great effort at
quarterback and it's one of the reasons
why the cardinals have been so bad most
people don't realize though that the
cardinals are the oldest team in the nfl
there's all this pomp and circumstance
about the packers and the bears
cardinals been around longer than either
of them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports